The tumors of my neck are HPV positive in the last week or two I've developed two
warts on my finger on the same side of the next tumor. So I think that's a
different virus. I don't think that's related. Does this mean that the HP
virus is still active in my system? Does that mean that though the HPV virus
like most viruses often stay latent in your body no better what you're doing so
that you have Epstein bar HPV other viruses in your body is you know fairly
ubiquitous. The awards are a different type of virus. I don't want one thing
about warts if you guys know often warts are a side of zinc difference zinc
deficiency. So look and see if you're getting getting a lot of zinc in your
body. Zic is really important for cancer patients as well. So zinc and
sodium are good for breast cancer and prostate cancer. Zic is good for all
cancers.